ammaji 2:09 your clearances on runway 1
1
a three and a half billion dollar gamble
by Canada's largest engineering firm
took to the skies September 16th after
nearly a decade of R&D and months of
delays the ft v1 is the first of five C
Series planes in Bombardier z' latest
testing program this first flight is
crucial both to drive sales and to prove
Bombardier can compete with Airbus and
Boeing our competitors have had a lot of
challenge on the development and the
entry into service so people are a
little bit you know gun-shy right now
Bombardier hopes its new planes can take
a sizable share of the market that's
dominated by Boeing 737 max and Airbus's
a320neo these border numbers currently
dwarfed those for the C Series what we
quickly realized is the customers only
have the choice of of these aircraft and
airlines are demanding lower fuel costs
lombardia claims the C Series with its
Pratt & Whitney turbofan engines are 25%
more fuel efficient with only half the
emissions we're specifically sized for
this market I think we're best suited
really to fill the market we're a
lower-cost developer we're a lower cost
producer but developing a new plane from
scratch takes serious commitment to
develop the product from when we
launched till today is approximately
five years actually get in service
you're talking like six seven years so
you really have to be a visionary and
believe in the strategy
bombardier will be chasing a market
totaling some 8,000 claims in the next
two decades
with the rise of other smaller firms
like Brazil's Embraer and Japan's
Mitsubishi the new jet age is expanding
we like competition
it drives innovation you either innovate
or you die